[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the MIT
Center for Art, Science,
and Technology's 2021 symposium,
Unfolding Intelligence--
The Art and Science of
Contemporary Computation.
CAST was established
in 2012, with the goal
of building and
building on connections
between the worlds of art,
science, and technology.
This is the third in
a series of symposia
that CAST has
convened since then,
and as with its predecessors,
we bring together artists,
scientists, engineers, and
humanists from within MIT
and from the world at
large to discuss areas
of rapidly evolving research
and urgent social relevance,
and to find in that dialogue
stimulation, confirmation,
provocation, intersection,
and, we hope, common purpose.
At MIT, CAST partners with
departments, labs, and centers
to integrate the arts
across the curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide
support to faculty and
members of the MIT community
as they pursue their
own artistic practice
and/or research.
In addition to
symposia like this,
CAST facilitates the sharing
of this creative work
beyond the Institute
by producing concerts,
exhibitions, and
publications, and making
them available to the public.
So thank you for
being with us today.
We hope you will join
us throughout the week
at virtual events addressing
the aesthetic, technical,
and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media.
We also look forward to seeing
you on Friday, April 9th,
as the symposium culminates
with a live interactive event
to which all attendees are
invited, at which you can join
presenters and artists
in breakout rooms
to explore hidden
threads between all that
has been discussed this week.
Welcome.
My name is Caroline
Jones, and I'm
an art historian teaching in
the History Theory Criticism
section of the Department
of Architecture here at MIT.
This is a pre-recorded
introduction
to the second of two sessions
on the theme of open systems
in the Unfolding
Intelligence Symposium hosted
by the Center for Art, Science,
and Technology, known as CAST.
These sessions are also
supported by MIT'S Transmedia
Storytelling Initiative.
Once again, I want to thank
[? Millin ?] postdoc Will
Lockett, and cast
director Leila Kinney
for making this
symposium a reality,
as well as Katherine Higgins,
who served as the Open Systems
session producer.
Please feel free to ask
questions at any time
during the webcast.
You'll also find links to
other events in the symposium.
Our colleagues at the
List Visual Arts Center
have their own hosted related
events on artists and AI
that I hope you can
sign up for and attend.
I want to begin my brief
introduction tonight
by speaking the words of
MIT's recently achieved land
acknowledgment.
Although we gather virtually,
the resources and capacities
of MIT come from being
a land-grant university,
based on the ongoing
occupation and colonization
of previously occupied land.
MIT acknowledges
Indigenous Peoples
as the traditional
stewards of this land,
recognizing the
enduring relationship
that exists between them and
their traditional territories.
The land on which we gather
is the traditional unceded
territory of the Wampanoag
Nation, among others.
We acknowledge the painful
history of genocide
and the forced occupation
of their territory,
and we honor and respect
the many diverse Indigenous
People connected to this
land from time immemorial.
Acknowledging the living
indigenous communities here
in Massachusetts is
really important to me,
and this evening's session
opens directly onto questions
of indigenous
epistemologies of kinship
and biological
theories of mutualism
that our panelists will discuss.
Following their
pre-recorded presentations,
we'll engage in
a live discussion
and Q&A. Mutualism emerges
from Professor Fredrickson's
biological study of
entangled ecologies,
while professor Lewis
argues that kinship can also
be forged with our machine
learning prostheses,
potentially as proxies for
other species with whom
we share the planet.
The way that both of them
utilize computation and think
about the promise of AI is
the fascinating conversation
I look forward to engaging
them with tonight.
We'll begin with Professor
Frederickson, followed
by Professor Lewis.
I'll then open
out our discussion
to your synchronous
questions and answers.
Megan Frederickson
has been engaged
with the biology of
social insects, plants,
and their symbionts for decades.
Educated at Harvard
as an undergrad,
she did her PhD at
Stanford and runs a lab
on mutualism,
ecology, and evolution
at the University of Toronto.
Fredrickson's work on
mutualism and its role
in driving evolution requires
that biological events
be converted into data--
data that might be
necessary to convince
remnant Darwinists
obsessed with survival
of the fittest, predicated
on individual reproductive
success, that we actually need
to think about other units
of evolutionary fitness
and combinations
of communities that
evolve together.
While field analysis
alone might inform us
about native and invasive ants
as seed spreaders, for example,
we need rapid throughput
genomic analysis
to tell us about
holobionts and hologenomes
in these complex
plant/animal societies.
Megan is writing a book that
aims to synthesize mutualism
in microbiome research in
order to better understand when
and which microbes are
beneficial to their hosts,
including humans, and how we can
make the most of microbes which
are everywhere on this planet.
So for those at
Jenna Sutela's talk
this morning, you'll recognize
a consistent [? troubling ?]
of the cranial model of
intelligence, that idea
that a brain can be analogized
to a centralized computer
mainframe or motherboard
with its circuits and command
centers.
Sutela and Frederickson
both point to the fact
that there's intelligence
in the microbial gut brain
that we are still
trying to figure out.
There's also intelligence
in the immune brain that
learns and remembers from
its encounters with vaccines
and viruses.
There is superorganismic
intelligence in the ant colony,
and even a kind of
homeostatic intelligence
in our beleaguered
planetary systems.
Frederickson is building
a laboratory system
that wants to engage these
questions quite precisely.
She hopes to do massively
parallel host microbe
experiments in hopes of testing
the effects of thousands
of microbial communities, along
with their mutualist symbionts.
This is important.
When we assess the
impact of termites
on the African
ecology, for example,
we need to reckon with the fact
that these eusocial insects
don't even have the capacity
to digest wood in their guts
without symbiotic
protists carried along.
They form lifelong relationships
with quite different species
that must evolve
with them and are
responsible for
managing an ecosystem
dependent on their activities.
By naming this
session Open System,
I aimed precisely to open
ideas of intelligence
to this kind of questioning--
the broader conversation about
models of sentience and ways
of knowing among and
between planetary forms.
Frederickson uses genetic
analysis and thinks with
algorithms to trace evolutionary
changes among mutualists
in an ecosystem, such as
a recent paper about this
Caribbean plant known
as the yellow alder,
crucial to a particular
butterfly-- the tawny coster--
which lays its eggs on this
particular plant's leaves.
The evolution of mating
and reproductive systems
involve all members of
this mutual relationship,
confronting the
tendency of biologists
to speak of parasites
and hosts or talk
about cheaters and altruists.
Fredrickson's lab
offers a recent study
of rhizobial bacterial
genomics inside legume roots.
As she will discuss in her
pre-recorded presentation,
she and her colleagues
showed that the evolution
of bacterial bonds
solicited by these legumes
is what drives the
evolutionary outcome
of the mutualist system.
Bacteria confer
fitness on the legumes
and evolved toward greater
mutualism, not less.
Bacteria are crucially part
of the environment, which also
is a partner in this dynamic.
Although Frederickson
acknowledges
that the classical biological
definition of kinship
does not allow her to call these
symbiotic mutualisms of legumes
and their bacteria kinship,
maybe this symposium
will encourage her to
persuade biology otherwise.
Think how useful
such a concept could
be in describing a situation in
which a nitrogen-starved plant
sends out a chemical
signal for help, growing
nodules on its fruit to welcome
the necessary nitrogen-fixing
bacteria from the environment.
In one recent analysis
by biochemist Maroti
and Kondorosi, exchanges
of signal molecules
between the partners,
bacteria and legume,
leads to the formation
of root nodules
where bacteria are converted
to nitrogen-fixing bacteroides.
In other words,
the bacteria change
from free-dwelling in
the soil to endosymbionts
in their new dependency
on the legume
for photosynthesise nutrition.
Jason Edward Lewis
understands the power
of such non-sanguineous
kinships.
He brings into this discussion
an acute awareness of TEK--
traditional environmental
knowledge-- in confrontation
with our Western models
of technocratic mastery.
TEK produces an active
link with the teaching
of elders and ancestors,
which Lewis recently
celebrated in his native
Hawaii, and as it is recently
being re-evaluated in something
like the controlled burns
of the California high drylands.
Those were originally
conducted by First Peoples,
dismissed by Western
management techniques,
and are now being re-solicited
to manage those fragile lands.
Like Frederickson, Lewis was
also educated at Stanford,
where he received a
degree in symbolic systems
before going to the Royal
College of Arts for an MPhil
degree in design.
Professor Lewis is
both a creative coder
and a media artist.
He has also been
a profound mentor
of generations of Indigenous
media theorists and artists.
Professor of Computation
Arts and University Research
Chair in Computational
Media, he also
runs the Initiative
for Indigenous Futures
from his post at
Concordia University.
In all these endeavors,
Lewis has given us
an entirely new and fruitful
way of thinking about kin--
notably, in his
collaborative polemic,
published in MIT's own
Journal of Design and Science,
Making Kin With the Machines.
The authors, who identify
variously as Cree, Lakota,
and Hawaiian hold that
many different Indigenous
epistemologies
converge on methods
for making respectful
relationships with minerals,
microbes, and machines, as
well as animals, of course,
giving us forms of knowing
that can help us move away
from the anthropocentric
troubles we find ourselves in.
As a scholar of Hawaiian,
Cherokee, and Samoan
descent himself, Lewis
puts these epistemologies
to work in his own creative
computational poetics.
I'm showing you here an excerpt
from his poem Quartet, which
falls on the 2019
science fiction book
by Adrian Tchaikovsky,
Children of Ruin,
about an octopoid intelligence
on a terraformed planet.
Lewis's poem segues
into an imagining
of a troika of AI
companions based
on the intelligence of
the honorable octopus put
at the service of a young
Hawaiian adolescent.
In addition to stimulating
Lewis's poetry,
this [? oco-akamai ?] AI is in
tune with deeply-held Hawaiian
concepts of responsibility
and reciprocity within
the ecosystem.
These poems and
meditations are published
within a document Lewis edited
in 2019 and published in 2020,
The Indigenous Protocol
for AI, an IP thinking
about the potentials
and colonizing perils
of artificial intelligence.
The document was the
pre-COVID achievement
of an extraordinary gathering
of scholars and thinkers,
including our own esteemed
colleague D. Fox Harrell,
who's running a different
session in this symposium.
These critical
approaches to IP and AI
want to open out those
systems to our scrutiny
as well as welcoming our
multigenerational and
multi-species imagination.
In conclusion, if this
morning's conversation
prompted artist Jenna Sutela
and curator-theorist Lars Bang
Larsen to think about AI
as alien intelligence,
addressing how we might imagine
potential kinds of sentience
that our planet's
not-yet encountered,
then this evening's prompts
us to think about AI as kin.
Frederickson and
then Lewis will help
us unfold machine
intelligence as a tool
for revealing mutualisms and
a creative device for creating
more-than-human alliances.
Let us turn, then, to
these amazing panelists
[? with ?] their open systems,
engaging life and machines.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Megan Frederickson,
and I'm a professor of Ecology
and Evolutionary Biology at
the University of Toronto.
My talk today is entitled
Animal, Plant, and Microbial
Life, Interconnected.
So I study mutualism
and symbiosis,
two words that are often
used interchangeably,
but are not actually synonyms.
So symbiosis means different
species living together
in close association,
like corals
and their microscopic,
photosynthetic algae,
or leguminous plants and the
nitrogen-fixing bacteria they
house in root nodules, or
grazing mammals and their gut
microbes.
Mutualism, in contrast,
means all interactions
between species in which
both species or all species
benefit from the
interaction, whether or not
the species actually
live together.
Maybe most symbioses, or
probably most symbioses,
are mutualisms.
But not all mutualisms
are symbiotic.
So for example, plants
and their pollinators
are generally mutually
beneficial interactions,
even though they don't
actually live together.
And mutualisms in
symbiosis are everywhere,
all around us all the time.
These interactions make
fundamental but often
underappreciated contributions
to ecosystem functions
that sustain biodiversity.
Globally, most pollination, seed
dispersal, biological nitrogen
fixation, photosynthesis
in coral reefs,
and digestion in mammalian
guts happens mutualistically.
Humans also have both
symbionts and mutualists.
We live in close association
with the diverse microorganisms
that colonize our bodies,
especially our guts.
Sometimes, this community
of microorganisms
is called the human
microbiome, which
is currently a hot area
of research in biology.
And we can also think
about the interactions
that humans have with crops or
with livestock as mutualisms
in which both species benefit.
So this is my son actually
picking strawberries at a farm
last summer.
But I don't really study humans.
In fact, I don't even
study vertebrates.
I study plants and
insects and microbes,
which are far more
diverse on our planet
than vertebrates are.
And my research
aims to understand
how mutualisms and symbiosis
links the fate of interacting
species in ecosystems, and
how these interconnections
between species have shaped
the evolution of life on Earth.
So mutualism is a
form of cooperation.
And cooperation is an
extremely widespread phenomenon
at all levels of
biological organization.
We can think of
genes cooperating
in genomes, organelles
cooperating in cells,
cells cooperating in
multicellular bodies,
and individuals cooperating in
societies, including our own.
And mutualism is just
cooperation between species.
It's also so widespread
that most plants and animals
engage in mutualism with
at least one other species
that they depend on for
nutrition, or protection,
or dispersal.
And I study mutualism and
symbiosis in the wild,
working at field stations
in both the Peruvian Amazon
and here in Canada
and elsewhere.
And I also bring insects
and plants and microbes
into my lab at the University of
Toronto to study their traits,
or their behaviors,
or their genes
in ways that would be
impossible in the field.
And increasingly, like
many other biologists,
I also use computational
and bioinformatics methods
to quantify patterns in
larger, complex data sets.
I'm showing you some
video of one interaction
that I've studied for many
years between an Amazonian plant
and the ants that
it feeds and houses.
So each branch on this
tree has a hollow swelling
like the one you can
see in the middle
of those leaves in the video.
And if you were to cut open that
hollow swelling on the branches
on this tree, you would
find them full of ants
and their eggs and larvae.
And this tree
species has actually
evolved to make this specialized
form of housing for ants.
And it also makes these
tiny little food bodies,
which are too small
to see in the video.
But it makes them to feed
the ant colonies that
live inside its branches.
Why?
Well, these ants may be
small, but they are aggressive
and have a really
powerful sting.
And they attack any herbivores
that land on the plant,
including this grasshopper
that you can see in the video--
or what's left of it anyways.
So the ants defend the plant
against the plant's enemies,
and the plant nourishes
and shelters the ants.
An excellent example of
cooperation between species.
But cooperation is supposed
to have a dark side.
Cooperation, in
all its forms, is
supposed to break down
because of the evolution
of selfish cheating strategies.
Evolutionary biologists
think about a population
of co-operators,
which are shown here
in the slide in the blue Cs.
And these co-operators--
these blue Cs--
benefit others in
their population
at some short-term
cost to themselves.
But they recoup
that short term cost
by also receiving benefits
from other co-operators
in their population.
But imagine if there
was a new genotype--
the red D here--
that arises by mutation
in this population.
And what makes the
red genotype different
is that it no longer
provides any benefits
to the other members
of the population.
And thus, it saves on
the short-term costs
of cooperation.
But the red Ds still
receive benefits from others
in the population, and thus
have higher fitness than
the co-operators--
than the blue Cs--
because they get all
of the same benefits,
but pay none of the costs.
Thus, the red D is a
cheater or defector genotype
that is favored by
natural selection.
And we predict it should
spread in the population.
If all else is equal,
which it never is,
we would therefore expect
that the red D genotype
would spread to fixation.
And we would have started with
a population of co-operators--
the blue Cs--
and ended with a population of
non-co-operators-- the red Ds.
In other words, we
would expect cooperation
to break down,
given enough time.
So why do we still
observe cooperation
in all its glorious
forms throughout nature?
How cooperation evolves
and is maintained in nature
despite the threat
of selfish cheating
is a question with
a very long history
in evolutionary biology.
And I'm not really going to
have time in my 15-minute talk
today to do it justice.
But very briefly, we have
known for a long time
that this puzzle is solved if
the donor and the recipient
of the cooperation are related,
meaning they share genes.
The British geneticist
J.B.S. Haldane
is said to have remarked
that he would not give up
his own life to
save one brother,
but he would lay down his
life for two brothers or eight
cousins.
Why?
Because in humans,
siblings share, on average,
half their genes,
and first cousins,
share on average, an eighth.
The idea that
cooperation can evolve
if it's directed
at relatives or kin
was further formalized
by W.D. Hamilton
in 1964 in a pair of
foundational papers.
And it's still one of
the leading explanations
for how cooperation
evolves between individuals
of the same species.
For example, in bees and
ants and other insects
that live in colonies,
as well as in humans.
But it doesn't work
for mutualisms.
Mutualisms, by definition,
occur between members
of different species,
and are thus not kin.
Thus, Hamilton's explanation for
the evolution of cooperation,
which is often known
as kin selection,
cannot explain the
evolution of mutualism.
Nonetheless, mutualism
and symbiosis clearly
evolve and persist in nature.
They're all over
the place when we
look around the natural world.
And my research has repeatedly
shown that mutualism--
oh, sorry-- that
cheating does not
threaten mutualism evolution.
I wrote an opinion article
a few years ago entitled
Mutualisms Are Not on
the Verge of Breakdown,
arguing that despite a lot
of attention to the cheater
problem, we rarely actually
see cheaters in nature,
and there is little evidence
that mutualisms break down
into parasitisms over
evolutionary time.
In short, mutualisms don't
go over to the dark side.
Moreover, there are
reasons to think
that the evolution of
mutualism and symbiosis
actually generates new life
forms and new functions that
can lead to ecological
and evolutionary success.
So to give just one
example, the eukaryotic cell
is the product of an
ancient symbiosis.
And of course, this
new kind of cell
gave rise to all the plants
and animals and fungi
that are on the planet today.
As Lynn Margulis and
Dorion Sagan once wrote,
"life did not take
over the globe
by combat, but by networking."
So I want to briefly describe
one recent research project
from my lab to give you the
flavor of the kind of work
that I do, and also to
convince you that cooperation
can evolve easily and fast.
So this project involves the
legume-rhizobia symbiosis shown
in cartoon form on this slide.
Leguminous plants-- including
many that you are familiar
with, like soybeans--
have symbiotic bacteria
called rhizobia that live
inside nodules on their roots.
Those little
circles on the roots
are the nodules that house
these symbiotic bacteria.
And all plants need nitrogen.
And there's lots and lots
of nitrogen in the air.
But it's in a form that
plants can't use for growth.
But rhizobia and
some other bacteria
are capable of doing
something really special.
They can take
nitrogen from the air
and turn it into
plant-accessible forms,
a process called
nitrogen fixation.
And of course, plants
can do something special
that a lot of bacteria can't do.
And that is they
can photosynthesize.
And they can take carbon
dioxide from the air
and turn it into sugar,
which bacteria also need.
So legumes and rhizobia
form a symbiosis
in which they exchange
plant-fixed carbon
and bacteria-fixed nitrogen
to their mutual benefit.
+ is economically and
ecologically important,
because there are
many crops and forage
plants that are
symbiotic legumes,
and because biological nitrogen
fixation done by bacteria
is really critical to nutrient
cycling in ecosystems.
So in my lab, we've done a lot
of work on how in the wild,
there's lots of variation among
rhizobia in how much nitrogen
they can fix and how much
they help their plants grow.
And we wanted to find out
whether we could evolve
better symbionts in the lab.
So we took rhizobia and
added them to sterile plants,
and allowed them to grow.
And when the plants
got big enough,
we cut off the
above-ground plant parts--
so the leaves and the stems--
and let the roots die,
and re-released bacteria
into the soil.
Then, we planted another seed
of the same type of plant,
and repeated this
process five times
in a greenhouse experiment
lasting about a year.
We used five different
plant genotypes--
you can think of genotypes
as different varieties
of the same species of plant--
always giving the bacteria a
new seed of the same plant type.
And at the end of
the experiment,
we isolated and
cultured the microbes,
tested them on new
host plants, and then
measured how many
nodules they formed
and how much they
helped plants to grow.
So this is what the experiment
looked like in the greenhouse,
with bacteria evolving
in those pots of soil
beneath all those
little legumes.
And this is what we found.
So each one of
these panels labeled
with a number across the top
is a different plant genotype
or variety.
And we tested the bacteria
at the end of the experiment
both on the plant genotype
that they evolved on
in the greenhouse experiment
and on all the other kinds
of plant phenotypes,
which they hadn't
seen during their yearlong
evolution in the greenhouse.
And that's indicated
on the x-axis
as whether the bacteria
shared evolutionary history
with their host.
So the left-hand panel shows how
much the bacteria helped plants
to grow, how large
the plants grew
with different
kinds of bacteria,
and the right-hand panel shows
how many nodules those bacteria
formed on plants.
And what I hope you can see
is that in general, bacteria
formed more nodules
and made plants
grow bigger when they had
evolved with that plant
genotype for a year.
So the microbes got better
at cooperating with plants.
They became better mutualists,
but only with the host
they were paired with during the
year-long evolution experiment.
So I've just shown you that
we can evolve better symbionts
in the lab.
We can make microbes
that are more
cooperative with their hosts.
And one current big
idea in the field
is that it might be possible
to evolve or engineer
microbial symbionts for a wide
range of beneficial purposes,
be those applications in
health or in agriculture
or in biodiversity conservation.
Maybe we can design microbial
strains or communities
that improve human or
ecosystem health or well-being.
But the main problem is that
microbes are not, in fact,
machines.
They are living organisms
that do not just
stay where you put them.
They do not necessarily
work in predictable ways,
or as the designer intended.
They disperse, they jump
from one house to another,
and they evolve.
So I think the jury
is still out on
whether evolving or engineering
microbiomes will really
work as some have envisioned.
So what does this all mean
for artificial intelligence?
I haven't really said much about
AI today, and I am no expert,
but I will say this.
In my area of biology,
we often think
about microbes behaving
according to simple algorithms,
and evolving, and interacting
in tiny experimental microcosms
as just one step removed from
a simulation model running
on the computer.
Microbes in the lab add
only a little bit of realism
above what happens in
silico, and they are still
a far cry from the complexity
of real natural ecosystems.
So in my lab, we
spend a lot of time
thinking about what
conditions and designs select
for cooperation among beings
that don't share genes,
and when, if ever,
we would expect
to see the evolution of
selfishness or cheating.
And this seems like also
a worthwhile question
to ponder as humans
design and create
ever more intelligent machines.
And with that, I'd
like to acknowledge
the people, institutions, and
funders that have supported
my recent research.
And I look forward
to the discussion.
Hello, everybody.
I want to start by thanking
the organizers for inviting me
to this panel, and to Dr. Jones,
in particular, for moderating
and bringing Megan
and I together
for preliminary conversation.
I am speaking from Tiohtiake,
known in settler Canada
as Montreal, on the traditional
territory of the Kanienkehaka
Nation.
I want to preface
these brief comments
by noting that as I use
the term Indigenous,
I'm talking specifically
of a North American Pacific
Islander and Australia
and New Zealand context.
And I want to underline
that I'm not here
to speak on behalf of
any Indigenous peoples,
but rather to report on the work
that my Indigenous colleagues
and I have been doing.
So today, I'm going to talk
about the work of an Indigenous
protocol and artificial
intelligence working group.
For me, that story
starts with Making
Kin with the Machines,
an article I co-wrote
in 2018 with three colleagues:
Noelani Arista, a historian who
was based at the University
of Hawaii at the time;
Archer Pechawis, a Cree
performance artist who's
based in Toronto; and
Suzanne Kite, a Lakota PhD
candidate who works with me.
Our goal was to
try to understand
what artificial
intelligence might
mean within our particular
Indigenous context.
In the essay, we write,
"We believe that Indigenous
epistemologies are much better
and respectfully accommodating
the non-human.
We retain a sense
of community that
is articulated through
complex kin networks anchored
in specific territories,
genealogies, and protocols.
Ultimately, our goal is
that we, as a species,
figure out how to treat
these new, non-human kin
respectfully and reciprocally."
One way to think about this
is to understand that each
of our cultures--
Hawaiian, Kree, and Lakota--
when confronted with a
new entity, ask first,
how are you related to me?
Rather than, what is that?
That is true for other humans,
certainly, but also animals,
stones, mountains, and oceans.
That first question
illustrates a view
of the world that
sees all encounters
through a relational lens
first, even before essence,
and certainly before utility.
How each of our
cultures articulates
that relationality is
expressed through protocol--
in other words, the procedures
for recognizing and maintaining
those relationships.
Protocol is very important
within our cultures,
as it guides us in how
to live a good life.
For instance, Hawaiians
understand themselves
as links in a genealogical
chain that places us
in a kinship relationship
with the ocean
and the creatures
of sea and land.
As Dr. Arista writes,
"Kanaka maoli ontologies
make it difficult and
outright unrewarding
to reduce pono, or balance,
to a measure of one,
to prioritize the benefit of
individuals over relationships.
Healthy and fruitful balance
requires multiplicity
and a willingness to continually
think in and through relation,
even when-- perhaps
particularly when--
engaging with those
different from ourselves.
A Kanaka maoli approach
to understanding AI
might seek to attend to the
power of mana that is exchanged
and shared between humans.
In attending to
questions of mana,
I emphasize our
preference of reciprocity
and relationship-building
to take the pono--
here meaning good or benefit--
take the pono of those in
relation into consideration."
Cree people situate everything
in a circle of relationships.
As Mr Pechawis writes,
"In Cree epistemology,
relationship is paramount.
Nehiyawewin, or
Plains Cree Language,
divides everything into
two primary categories:
animate and inanimate.
One is not better
than the other;
they are merely different
states of being.
These categories are flexible.
Certain toys are
inanimate until a child
is playing with them, during
which time they are animate.
A record player is
considered animate,
while a record, radio, or
television set is inanimate.
But animate or
inanimate, all things
have a place in our circle
of kinship, or wahkohtowin."
Stones exemplify the
complex set of protocols
that govern how the
Lakota approach kinship
with the non-human.
Ms. Kite write, "Standing
Cloud, or Bill Stover,
communicates Lakota
ethics and ontology
through speaking about
the interiority of stones.
These ancestors that
I have in my hand
are going to speak through me,
so that you will understand
the things that
they see happening
in this world and
the things that they
know to help all people.
Stones are considered ancestors.
Stones actively speak.
Stones speak through
and to humans.
Stones see and know.
Most importantly,
stones want to help.
The agency of stones connects
directly to the question of AI,
as AI is formed not only
from code, but from materials
of the Earth.
To remove the concept of
AI from its materiality
is to sever this connection.
In forming a relationship to
AI, we form a relationship
to the minds and the stones."
If all things might
potentially be a relation,
this certainly includes
the tools we make.
In the field of
AI, we are crafting
systems whose goal is to be
human-like in intelligence,
to which we are giving agency
we've previously only given
to humans, which are being
used to assess human behavior--
and in some cases, make
judgments about that behavior--
and which, on the outside edge
of the science fiction dream,
may achieve some form
of sentience, maybe even
consciousness.
These are systems in which
we already are in relation,
and that relationship
is only going
to grow and become more complex
as the technology advances.
Indigenous cultures have
tools, languages, protocols,
and epistemologies that
remain robust in articulating
these types of relationships.
As the Making Kin with the
Machines essay was being
written, I worked with
two other colleagues--
[? Angie ?] [? Abdullah, ?]
a Trawlwoolway designer based
in Sydney; and
Oiwi Parker-Jones,
a Hawaiian neuroscientist
working at Oxford.
We put together two workshops in
the winter and spring of 2019.
These were called the Indigenous
Protocol and AI Workshops,
and they were attended
by 35 participants
with representation from
15 indigenous communities
from across Aotearoa, Australia,
North America, and the Pacific.
One of the Unfolding
Intelligences organizers, Dr.
Fox Harrell, and his graduate
student, Danielle Olson,
were among those who joined
us to lend their good minds.
The group included
neuroscientists,
cultural knowledge holders,
computer scientists, poets,
language keepers, visual
artists, hula teachers,
venture capitalists,
historians, software engineers,
language keepers, and others.
The workshop conversation
covered extensive ground,
including epistemology, cultural
protocols, machine learning,
colonization, temporal
models, ontology, sentience
versus consciousness, software
architectures, and linguistics.
Out of those conversations came
the Indigenous Protocol and AI
Position Paper, which we
published in July of 2020.
Indigenous
epistemologies generally
approach the discovery,
refinement, transmission,
and preservation of knowledge
as inherently multidisciplinary.
As such, the Position Paper
features artistic excursions
as well as analytical
essays, and poetry as well as
profiles of prototypes
built during the workshops.
Here's a small sampling.
Suzanne Kite,
mentioned previously,
wrote a chapter called How
to Build Anything Ethically.
She examines the protocol
her people, the Lakota,
use to build sweat
lodges in order
to develop a methodology for
building computational systems
in a good way.
Michelle Brown is
another PhD student
who works for us from the
University of Hawaii at Manoa.
She wrote a chapter
on how she imagines
for Indigenous [? Basque ?]
community harness harnessing AI
to support them in their
relationships with the ocean.
Given the centrality of
the eel to her culture,
she designed the technology
to mimic eel behavior,
creating the Txitxardin,
an oceangoing AI relative.
One of my contributions
is to imagine
a young Hawaiian growing up
alongside three different AI
systems.
One is modeled after
process-oriented Indigenous
languages, such as Blackfoot, as
described by Leroy Little Bear.
One takes its foundation
in Hawaiian epistemologies
of abundance.
And the third uses the neural
architecture of an octopus
to translate between the first
two and advise the youth.
We also had a project
that prototyped
a piece of Indigenous design
language translation software.
Noe Arista, Caroline Running
Wolf, Michael Running Wolf,
Caleb Moses, and Joel
Davison worked together
to create Hia Ki'i, an app that
allows you to use your camera
phone to look at objects
in your environment
and get community-verified
Hawaiian language
descriptions of them.
And Dr. Hemi Whaanga
wrote about the potential
for AI systems and
related technologies
to be used against
Indigenous peoples
as an extension of colonial
practices of exploitation,
extraction, and
control, particularly
those that displace a people's
understanding of themselves
with a worldview that
favors the colonizer.
He writes, "The colonization of
the culture, language, and mind
takes place through the
transmission of mental habits
and contents by means
of social systems
other than the
colonial structure.
These social systems
include cultural practices,
language, and technologies, such
as artificial intelligence."
We also developed guidelines for
Indigenous-centered AI designed
to reflect in condensed form
the themes and concerns that we
found most important.
I want to highlight
several of those themes.
Relationality and
its consequence,
reciprocity, are the
core of humanness,
and are how we produce
knowledge that is worth knowing.
AI systems should be
designed to understand
how humans and
non-humans are related to
and interdependent
on each other.
Understanding,
supporting, formalizing,
and encoding these relationships
is a primary design goal.
Indigenous knowledge is often
rooted in specific territories.
AI systems should be
designed hyperlocally,
meaning in partnership
with specific Indigenous
communities, and
should be responsible
to those communities,
provide relevant support,
and be accountable to those
communities first and foremost.
And finally, all
AI systems should
be designed to respect and
support data sovereignty.
Indigenous communities
must control
how their data is solicited,
collected, analyzed,
and operationalized.
They decide when to protect
it and when to share it,
where the cultural intellectual
property rights reside
or if they even want to deal
with that sort of framework,
and to whom those rights adhere.
So I want to close with
two provocations that
grow out of this work.
The AI industrial complex
doesn't have an ethics problem.
It has an epistemology problem.
The persistent
infections of bias
are simply symptoms
of this deeper issue.
The epistemology problem stems
from a series of assumptions
that are built into how
we design and deploy
our computational
systems: the users
is an individual, the
individual is primarily
concerned with maximizing
their personal well-being,
culture is a second-order
effect, rather than
the primary phenomenon, and that
the only useful knowledge is
that produced through
rational instrumentality.
This makes AI system engineers
blind to important aspects
of human existence, such as
trust, care, and community,
that are fundamental to how
human intelligence actually
operates.
The refusal to engage,
explore, and operationalize
knowledge frameworks that
centralize these aspects
is a tremendous
scientific failing,
creating huge gaps
between what humans think
of as an intelligent
presence in the world
and what the industry
academic complex is building.
This, to me, is the cause of
the white supremacy that social
and computer scientists such
as [? Nobel, ?] [? Benjamin, ?]
[? Gabru, ?] and
[? Bulameni ?] have documented.
The bias in these systems
is not a bug, but rather
a feature of an interlocking set
of knowledge systems designed
over centuries to
privilege white men.
We need to be clear about this.
Furthermore, I have to
wonder if machine learning,
deep learning, and all the
different AI techniques that
rely on vast amounts
of data to work
are not fundamentally
ethically compromised.
Very little of that
data was collected
in a truly ethical manner.
The people who
produced that data
were not asked if
it be used this way.
They were not
compensated for this use,
and the use most likely does
not benefit them directly.
Indigenous people have a long
history with people like this--
scientists who behave as if our
data is a publicly available
resource that they can
use to make themselves
famous or wealthy and
powerful, all in the name
of the greater good, of
increasing humanity's store
of knowledge.
Indigenous folks see people
like that coming a mile away,
and recognize them for
what they are: colonizers.
AI system builders who do
not understand the cultures
in which they operate cannot
understand how their systems
actually perform.
As scientists, they
should be ashamed at how
narrow-minded they are.
As engineers, they should
be embarrassed at how badly
their technology
fits their use case.
We should expect more from them.
In the meanwhile,
my colleagues and I
will continue building
capacity within our communities
so that we can design
and build AI systems
ourselves that are
better suited to helping
our particular
communities thrive--
ones that look beyond
impoverished models
of intelligence to develop ones
that are based on abundance.
Thank you.
I am looking forward
to the conversation.